hi I'm Rachel Senna hi I'm Emma Seligman
and I'm Iowa debris hi and we're here to
ask each other questions about our new
movie bottoms for Fandango yes tonight
is our night we're getting the couch I'm
gonna talk to Brittany you could say hi
to Isabelle what would I say hey girl
how's your boyfriend how's his penis
I'm gonna expel you both for committing
a crime against Jeff get out of the car
come on
um should I start yeah yeah okay so this
is a movie where Josie punches PJ in the
face
[Music]
um there is a scene yeah where Josie
punches PJ in the face what will you
remember most from making that scene
how hard it was for to nail the
placement
on your face yeah the trust uh the
trustful of it really like I remember
honestly the rehearsal of the punch of
to get up to making of that scene and
when we first started like
be punching each other in the face
because it's sort of like they show you
and you do it slow but then you just
kind of start doing it and it's like
okay punch me yeah yeah I think I'll
remember Rachel falling
because Rachel's a very flat follower I
struggle with Falls
what's your favorite memory of the fight
training for this movie
I feel like what yeah my do you want to
share your favorite no you start when we
were all in a circle like the first day
I wasn't part of the training obviously
like yeah this way at all but I feel
like the first day when we had Devin
McNair our stunt coordinator and she
just like took a moment to be like it's
so beautiful that I'm working with so
many women and like almost started
crying and then like
she literally went backwards and then
she was like all right time to toughen
up never mind no tears allowed um that
was one moment yeah
I was gonna say I loved the training of
the punching each other the falling on
the mats and I think just like the
supportive energy of it where it was
like
there was like some people were better
than others Ruby was incredible some
there were weak links and no no names we
have no idea who they don't know who
they are but and feeling like the
support of the group and then when Emma
would come in at the end of the first
week and we did like show and tell where
it's like and I was like watching us and
we're like come here
and then just like kicking each other
yeah Emma's like sideboarding with a
producer being like I I mean they've got
one more week so
not the ones that you choreographed but
look at somebody yeah yeah yeah that was
fun that was fun it was fun to show and
tell at the end of the day
Josie and PJ lie about having been to
juvie what's the best lie you've ever
told unless it's still currently going
on yeah you're exempt from
thank you
best lie
I feel like it's all childhood lies I
feel like I I faked a fever with a flat
iron one but I didn't put it straight to
my head you just put it I put it on it I
put it on a um either it was paper towel
or a washcloth and then I put that on my
forehead for a while
um and I faked the fever yeah I also
faked my period by like painting on a
pad and like showing it to my dad and
being like I can't go to swim practice
so I was like literally I was like well
if I lie I go to hell
but dude I'm like I'm like me I'm like
21. I'm like when I go to hell no but I
was um I was like six and we had to
memorize Bible verses for church and say
them at the end of like every Friday uh
for like youth service and I didn't
remember mine in time so I wrote it on
the inside of my arm is that even a lie
is that just me doing something stupid
but I got caught reading it because
obviously I'm like hmm oh Jesus loves me
whatever and obviously I got caught
cause I'm like six and the Sunday school
teacher was like did you literally just
read that off your arm and I was like no
it was like show me your arm then and I
had to show my arm in front of everybody
and then I remember I like ran to the
back of the church and I was like crying
and then my aunt was like literally
everybody can see you like it's fine
like get up you're being nuts he was so
embarrassed yeah yeah can you relate to
that at all I feel like like well now I
feel like now if I ever will you relate
to hell right no I was afraid of how I
kept doing this Judaism bragging yeah
we I kept a list of my sins and I would
I remember like one time I was in the
shower and then there was an ant
crawling in the shower and so I put it
in the toilet and then I got back in the
shower and I thought about it drowning
and I felt guilty and then I came out of
the shower and it was still swimming and
I saved it with a nail file and I
brought it outside what wait it's okay
there's no line
[Laughter]
like rock on God bless of course but
sometimes you're just like oh I was like
five years old and I was like checking
my mom's bed to make sure she wasn't
raptured you know what I mean who can
relate
you ever been there who is the best
fighter of the cast Ruby Ruby Ruby yeah
all that Willow training yeah what was
your reaction to seeing the school's
mascot for the first time on set
well I I got to develop the look of it
so I feel like I was I was very excited
I was there in the the yeah I was
excited by the excitement coming from
the costume designer and the production
designer Eunice was like lots of
meetings about the size and the texture
and the the like the fuzziness of it or
the like yeah with references and models
and whatever but what was it like when
you first saw the mascot
yeah to see it on the field to
really see it it was uh in motion as
shown yeah in motion is a whole other
thing because it it moves the costume
it's alive it's alive Yeah Yeah Yeah
that poor actor it was warm that was the
the other thing is I was like it's hot
there was a lot of little fans and
taking breaks yeah of any past show or
movie you've worked on which character
would you love to see join Josie and
PJ's Fight Club Richie from the bear as
like like the assistant coach to Mr G
yeah oh my God and they need to be in
matching track suit well yeah because
they're two like middle-aged men going
through divorces like they need each
other bad and the support they're really
at taking out all of their inner trauma
on the group Evan's also like really
funny yeah yeah yeah easily
I mean I know you're watching Fandango
brother
I'm like also an Italian we need and
it's the the characters to tell you
wait Richie Evans character yeah it's
polish but doesn't he say it's Italian
culture yeah and then everybody's like
you're polish okay I feel like the I'm
like we need a little bit of that I just
love that I thought like you were just
like Evan was Italian you're like we
need an Italian no that's just like we
got an Italian but um
God help us we I think that would be
great what's another character well I
only have it should have a baby to pull
from I feel like Polly oh
would be great I like that I feel like
she'd come in with beaten moves being
like so I planned this already yeah I
actually worked this out with my own
stunt coordinator yeah I'm gonna add
this to the scene yeah what do you think
we're in Ruby as Hazel
they would have a really strange
Alliance I see that just as the two
planners yeah yeah
maybe Alice from bodies because she was
trying to fight she has only W like like
well I have to be oh no noise it can be
a character from something I've been
here yeah or it can be but okay never
mind no no no no let her have that yeah
yeah
[Laughter]
yeah I think that's great but yeah
that's a perfect answer yeah yeah okay
what is your favorite onset memory of
Marshawn Lynch oh tons tons tossing a
football with him yes oh my gosh that
was fun we had like a heart to heart one
day love and I was just like literally
my life was a dream he's so nice yeah
he's so kind I remember trying to make
him cry with a tear stick and he hated
it so much that's not my favorite memory
of him but it's a distinct one oh no
because his eyes were like he was like
this he was like I can't do this like
and then was like what is that and he
was so game to try it I was like do you
want to put on a tear stick for when
you're crying about your divorce and he
was like well I'm game like I couldn't
do anything like a method whatever I'm
literally a football player I can handle
whatever yeah and then he hated the tear
sticks so much this is just a memory
yeah
also running lines with him was like
incredible because he was just like I
want to get it right and I was like
literally every time you open your mouth
you say the funniest thing I've ever
heard of yeah we were like forget the
lines
like you don't even have to be a part of
the script you can play your own
character if you want yeah yeah what's
your favorite memory of shooting the
scene where Josie lightly Taps Jeff with
her car
I think being in the car there's
something about getting to like be in a
little like the new me and Havana in
between takes like listening to music or
talk you know what I mean and then being
like
like NYX on the app do you know what I
mean getting to like getting to like hit
someone with your car but not really but
like I like um after when we like there
was like a part where we got this we had
to stay in the car while but then like
while uh miles started his screaming
yeah because we couldn't like we weren't
like we couldn't like Drive Away
something about it and so I got to see
miles doing like the different
variations of him screaming for Jeff and
that was just so funny because miles is
a genius yeah he is a genius I think my
favorite part was watching all the
football players run again yeah I think
my favorite part was watching all the
football players run and jump off the
cars
to do like bad fake stunts yeah like to
roll over the hoods of the car and stuff
yeah
yeah also when the stun the driver who's
done driving the car I got to be in it
and it was like whoo it was a little
roller coaster ride
but you were there in security
it looks like you're pulling away really
good I know it does yeah I did get my
license that year yeah yeah yeah
of the cast who do you think was most
like their character Ruby
is that crazy oh sorry I know we just
thought we would be faster no I couldn't
think of an idea maybe Ruby maybe Ruby
um Ruby or summer
yeah summer brought a lot yeah yeah
um pretend the senior yearbooks comes
out oh no no that's too hard
um oh
um what cover sports did you join in
high school rugby
cross country
acapella
drama drama film
um I did ballroom dancing for a little
oh my god do you get a character shoe or
a ballroom shoe I did yeah yeah I
thought for a second you said shoot and
I was like what I went to a public
school no other characters yeah girl who
Edition in our sneakers it was a little
it was a little it was a little ragtag
yeah